so
these jackets are beautiful richard ford
has an eye for detail
sizing up the inventory at franco womo a
menswear boutique in san jose there's
something traditional but there's also
something very contemporary about the
color and the pattern you know that's
not your dad's
jacket as ford knows when it comes to
fashion there's so much more than meets
the eye
he shares that insight in the book dress
codes how the laws of fashion made
history
dress codes are rules about what people
can wear so employers or schools or
sometimes even the government might have
rules or laws regulating the things that
people can wear
but i also mean by dress codes the way
we decode the meaning of clothing and
attire because clothing is communicating
and it is signifying you know social
status identity social position
a self-proclaimed close horse ford is a
professor of civil rights and employment
law at stanford
and a surprising number of legal
disputes and litigation revolves around
dress codes women suing their employers
who require women and only women to wear
makeup or high-heeled shoes african
americans sue their employers over dress
codes that prohibit certain hairstyles
dress codes that forbid certain types of
clothing that
religious traditions require people to
wear like head coverings and as ford
uncovers it's a story as old as fashion
itself
when did clothing go from just putting
something on to fashion
in the book i talk about the birth of
fashion in the late 1300s before then
clothes were draped on the body think
togas or robes that's until tailoring
became
widespread among elites and that changed
the nature of clothing and fashion it
made it much more expressive it made it
much more personal
but not everyone was permitted to dress
for success so-called sanctuary laws
kept royal subjects in their place going
back to the 1500s under queen elizabeth
you knew your place in society based on
what you were able to wear and what you
were wearing and this was true all over
europe but in tudor england and
especially under queen elizabeth the
first they were what were called acts of
apparel that regulated clothing
according to social status and they were
quite detailed only
a knight of the guarder or higher in
rank would be allowed to wear a certain
type of silk or a certain color or a
certain fabric and there were gradations
all the way down the social spectrum for
centuries all the sartorial advances
were tailored to men all the way up to
the business suit it's practical it's
sensible and that reflects the ideals of
enlightened reason and also of
industriousness a new value at this
period of time and what's important
about that moment in the 1700s and some
historians describe it as the great
masculine renunciation so it's the
renunciation of all of the finery and
what have you but it is a masculine
enunciation to some extent women's
clothing perhaps becomes even more
elaborate in opposition to this new
streamlined male silhouette it would
take another 120 years for a similar
revolution in the female wardrobe the
flappers although i think from today's
perspective we tend to think of them as
frivolous we think of them dancing in a
nightclub right
yeah exactly cocktails daisy buchanan
from the great gatsby but in fact the
flappers started off as working class
women
racially diverse group of women women
who needed clothing to be practical and
wanted to have some of the freedom of
men the 20th century put fashion at the
forefront of many social movements from
the zoot suit in the 1940s to the
refined attire of the civil rights era
if you go back in history there were
laws in the united states that
prohibited negroes and slaves from
dressing above their condition so when
the civil rights protesters wore their
sunday best where they knew they would
be confronted by racist mobs that was
part of the symbolism of the demand for
dignity and the demand for respect that
sense of fashion resonated with ford's
father he trained as a tailor
when he was in college a birmingham
alabama native who used clothing to
distinguish himself professionally so he
would always examine suits he would pick
them up and
and he'd check to make sure that there
was a
floating what's called a floating canvas
you'd pull between and you know if it
wasn't there he could no not that one
that's glued together um and then when
he found one like this that was very
nice you know he well
okay maybe for men suits remain the
dominant dress code in offices for
centuries but from wall street to
silicon valley dressing down is now
business as usual
so the dress code has gone away in the
workplace and particularly around here
in the silicon valley this is what you
need to wear to work that includes
everything from yoga pants to hoodies
it may seem like there's nothing to it
but the rejection of the business suit
the rejection of formal attire that was
a big deal in the early silicon valley
tech companies and they were pretty
explicit about thinking that rejecting a
formal dress code was a way of rejecting
the uptight lockstep non-creative ethos
of older corporate america yeah think
outside the box don't trust the guy in
the suit right exactly this one piece of
clothing doesn't just have one set of
coded language or coded meaning because
so much depends on social context as
well it matters whether you're wearing
it in the middle of the silicon valley
or you're wearing it in the inner city
yeah all of those things change the
meaning of clothing for this casual now
where are we in 50 years right well i
imagine the casual trend is here to stay
but i talked to the creative director
from esquire and he said you know the
new generation is wearing jackets and
ties and it's exactly as you suggested
my dad wears a sweatshirt and sneakers
and so i do see a new generation of
young people who are dressing in a bit
more of a refined manner